well he's a black Muslim keep in mind
he's a black Muslim lady things trend he
thinks the LGBTQ it's kind of weird
let's be honest a lot of us do it
doesn't mean that we hate anybody but he
thinks it's a little bit odd that's his
greatest crime here he just made fun of
people who chopped off their [ __ ] you
know I there's been so much outrage over
this I watched the special I encourage
everybody to watch the new special
legend sticks and stones as a specialty
it's had the left in meltdown mode of it
over the last week in case you've missed
it for his special which is now
available on Netflix six and stones it
has been controversial I think that Dave
Chappelle talking about trans people
it's not Dave Chappelle at his finest
and he's talking about hey did you know
she she used to be a man yeah totally
unbiased her in her face just in case
you know he's never pull the wool over
the eyes on old Steven talk about a
special called sticks and stones this is
what's so funny it might as well just be
called screw you if you write a negative
review of this because you're offended
you're taking the bait and they took the
bait bait resist something else that
I've noticed it's a lot easier and we'll
get to the the Rotten Tomatoes the
critics reviews and I wanna actually
leave a review below because I'd like to
see what you guys think because we're
not all accredited reviewers on Rotten
Tomatoes apparently you know they
rejected us not long ago really I
noticed though that there are a lot of
written reviews that you consider
negative but not a lot of video review
and the reason for it is they don't want
to show clips because if they show the
clip to tell you how offensive it is
most people will see the clips and go
but it's funny
exactly keep keep in mind by the way
Dave Chappelle is explicitly anti-trump
k-pro relatively speaking gun control
Pro sometimes pro-choice kind of keeps
you guessing he takes jabs at everybody
in this special okay even a headline to
protest against Trump's so cut the
Muslim ban I know Asano Muslim ban but
for the sake of trying to keep this
short I'm going to say yeah well refer
to it so then why the outrage basically
it all boils down to the fact that Dave
Chappelle jokes about
genders yeah which should be fair game
cancel and over hoops right away Italy
done and before we get started um we
have gotten started I should say before
we continue let me get started like what
have you been doing this whole time
starting intro you're on drugs
it's important to note there's a trend
amongst a lot of the critics of
Chappelle yeah like the Rotten Tomatoes
one of the reviewers I think we have a
screen Ian Thomas Malone transgender
Amanda Carey at the Advocate transgender
hmm contra points who's embarrassed
quote for Chappelle
transit that's the one he used to be a
man yeah yeah
now on the woman used to be though just
because I wouldn't want it to cause any
effect thank you yes
so that might provide some insight and
give you some it's why the reviews are
so negative but we're going to look a
little more closely as to how they've
covered it couple of things that they've
done here this is something you see a
lot the left
they take comedy seriously right they've
been reporting on this special I
wouldn't even say as though it's an
op-ed in a newspaper they've been
covering it like it's a news article
yeah a newspaper not even the op-ed
section of Fox News I got even Hannity
or Carlson they're acting like it's Shep
Smith yeah straight down the middle
Transpo from the special these jokes are
really obvious and something Jim Norton
talks about and I think this is
important to kind of keep in mind why is
there no pass for comedians for some
reason there used to be more of a pass
for hip hop artists a little bit less
now except for a little no sex who came
out as gay who could have possibly seen
that one coming but they gave it a pass
quite a bit you know something go out
and sing about gang banging and choosing
hoes and selling crack they didn't have
a problem with Ludacris or jay-z right
it's about free speech but then
comedians if they tell a joke it's meant
to be taken entirely seriously whereas
really it's the art form that is
supposed to have the most amount of
leeway someone being facetious or Sarika
gesture
absolutely it's the lat it should be the
last safe haven for free speech in this
country and yet it's not let me spend a
lot of time mocking white people you
know he does and I don't want to go
where the identitarian is do like war is
that okay because a white genocide no I
funny when a black man does the basic
white guy all of them do here's another
thing that they claim they claim that
Dave Chappelle is punching down right
this is why they're so upset and this is
really typical of the left because we've
talked about this their worldview is
predicated on idea of societal structure
of classes of oppression and by the way
granting the automatic moral high-ground
to whoever they view as the underdog
that's why you support Palestine over
Israel even though they kill children
they target them deliberately that's
where they support people antiphon aoc
raises money for an to fight even though
they had weapons and they were attacking
cops so they just see you if you're the
underdog if you have less power than you
must be inherently morally right so in
this case they argue that Chappelle is a
bully because he's punching down it
transgenders and lest you think I make
this up I hate that we have to do this
clip from The Young Turks I'm like
you're doing it to be funny and to joke
but a lot yes we're saying similar
things are not doing it for that reason
Dave Chappelle in his special unit
watching he clearly demonstrates that
the lgbtq is he refers to his alphabet
people they are in power right and he
does and he under Kurds this with some
very funny bits he talks about how he he
wasn't allowed to say off on the
Chappelle show and he realized he'd
written an unwritten rule in Hollywood
right again he talks about the Alpha
people he's not punching down at all
he's punching up this is what's
important is there any case in point is
there any more powerful you know this
happy legal documents at some point here
is there any more powerful organization
out there that you can think of outside
of Google YouTube maybe maybe Facebook
but they're up there right when we're
talking about corporate overlords for
some reason when it's convenient for the
left they often don't mention Google and
YouTube's but let's assume they're
powerful let's say not number one
because I don't want to use an extreme
example to make a point I don't want to
I don't want to get her Billy here don't
do it because you might fact check me
they're actually Amazon is worth more
and if you shoot in from the hip I
didn't realize we're gonna fact-check
joke here you go CEO of YouTube look at
her
cowering before the LGBTQA AIP alphabet
community the decision that we made was
very hurtful to the LGBTQ community
really sorry about that I'm really
personally very sorry and I it was not
our intent and will speak to people from
the LGBTQ community make sure that we're
incorporating that going forward in
terms of how we think I am truly truly
sorry for the hurt that we caused a
community I really do apologize for the
for the hurt that we caused that's
harder to watch than Maggie Gyllenhaal
so correct them correct
not exactly but she does a gross
disservice to the International Clint
Howard look-alike foundation I just want
to make sure that you do not speak all
of them very clear the world's most
powerful big tech organizations shudder
in fear at the mere thought of a video
suggesting that hormone replacement
therapy for six-year-olds could be
unhealthy and that it might be found to
be trending that's what she's talking
about she's talking about this channel
by the way and this is the entire
purpose of comedy I think a lot of
people missed this the whole purpose of
comedy as an art form is to speak truth
to power is to poke your poke your
finger like your rahm emanuel in the
shower in the chest of the person who
has authority the court jester was the
only person allowed to mock the king at
all yeah yeah that's what it's designed
to do that's what Dave Chappelle was
doing and then these same people out
there say well listen how dare you bully
because one thing I think you're the
bully silence exactly right well he's a
black Muslim
keep in mind he's a black Muslim and he
made funny things trend he thinks the
LGBTQ it's kind of weird let's be honest
a lot of us do it doesn't mean that we
hate anybody but he thinks it's a little
bit odd that's what he talks about
that's his greatest crime here a Black
Muslim comedian who is largely shaped
black American culture for our
generation he's effectively this
generations Eddie Murphy right it would
be tough to argue against that he just
made fun of people who chopped off their
cooks that's not a stretch didn't say he
hated them he said that's kind of funny
all right this week a notification
battle hit it if you're subscribed
because
subscriptions don't mean anything or
just bookmark the page you can check
back every single day let's say I join
up Mudd Club you get Dave Rubin now he's
going to be here at the blaze when the
show launches we will give you the exact
it's pretty soon I don't know the exact
date yeah here's another thing that they
claimed to the left and handling.this
and I want to see if you disagree with
any that we're talking about here
because I understand this is a little
more nuanced I hate using that word but
it is they're also saying the left are
saying that because Chappelle said these
things in this special it must mean that
canceled culture is just a figment of
your imagination it feels like a lot of
comedians reach that point where all
they want to talk about is the stuff
that they're not allowed to talk about
that they always talk about yes yes
they're not allowed to even though they
did all nine it's almost as though
that's a comedian's job it seems to me
by the way he's straight it seems to me
that Lenny Bruce just wants to go up
stage and like point shine a light on
societal taboos this is important to
note is yes ship helpful because he's
already extremely famous but as he
points out in his special famous people
aren't immune it's easier for them but
look at Kevin Hart Kevin Hart was banned
I'm hosting the Oscars because he
effectively tweeted a gay joke now if
he's not actually Kevin Hart you know
what happens he's not banned from the
Oscars he's banned from speaking at
clubs from performing at comedy clubs
he's banned from speaking at colleges so
they have a little bit more leeway but
they're not completely immune and by the
way famous people they have their
reputations destroyed for far less so
here's something else to to keep in mind
Chappelle his clip from Netflix or he's
talking about Jesse small a Jesse small
it spoiler alert for BBC small a it was
trending number two on YouTube with um
bleep you use the word and the any say
the n-word he would say the n-word
so he said so repeatedly he said in this
and it was unbelief and I can't even say
you wanna see just you're hearing the
baby I'm saying the actual word so he
said there's gonna be a summit there's
gonna be a march you know I don't want
to say the word I'll be at the front
that March just a quarter of you though
you least defended if you repeated Dave
Chappelle's bit - Dave Chappelle and use
the words that he used now keep in mind
so he was allowed to make those comments
because he's famous there's so many way
our channel was nearly banded just for
having the word figs on a shirt so if
you need more evidence by the canceled
culture is real contra points the
transgender used to be a man by the way
right there you just watch a bashing
Chapelle on the internet to make sure
you get it right not anymore
it's an easy mistake to make one at
first glance he but clearly a woman now
so culture points contra points was
canceled yesterday for not being woken
up for trans Twitter there was a kid
against left us they're convinced that
um Chappell this is the argument they
finally Hughes in case you didn't agree
is it he's just out of touch with the
current audience it seems like he thinks
like this guy knows everyone feels the
way he feels but they won't say it right
so I just don't think that that's the
case
the problem is room he thinks that those
people laughing in that big room are
still how the entire world is great if
they're feeling to really listen to
their own audience what he's basically
saying is he thinks that everybody in
this theater laughing thinks that's
funny he's out of touch yeah I guess he
said of touch though if you look at the
run Tomatoes critic score versus the
audience from the audience waiting for
them to remove the audience score so
this is reliable yeah he is showing that
the left is demonstrably out of touch so
you could contrast that with Hannah
Gatsby's terribly unfunny Nannette
special it's got a hundred percent on
Rotten Tomatoes seriously from the
critics panned by the public only forty
percent did you say that's where she
goes there's nothing funny about self
deprecation self-deprecation is self
humiliation you're a fat lesbian
Australian self-humiliation is young
card you have to play so you got lady go
take it away a mini card I say this
humiliation is largely the only card I
have to play this is important first off
the the videos on Netflix there YouTube
millions of plays usually they're
getting a twenty five thousand play it
was a very very well video but they
couldn't silence him calling him a
racist because he's black but here the
same thing that conservatives did and he
went off the reservation and he
expressed an opinion that they don't
like their so they go home psych we have
to use the same tactic that we use
against conservatives to silence them we
can't say racist I know black people can
still be transphobic transphobic that's
what they do it's the same exact
technique they're just going to keep
going down the list and that's why peas
and crocodiles is futile but in the net
from Hannah Gatsby a hundred percent you
know what else while we're talking about
Adam touch knock down the house a
hundred percent from critics twenty five
percent from the audience but if none of
this works saying that he's a bully
saying that he's transphobic saying that
he's punching down saying is that up
touch what do they did this is what the
left always does with comedians they
just claim you guess it that he's done
fun time he doesn't he's talking about
he's kind of stuck at this very basic
level that he can't get past and it's he
could just not do the trans jokes
because he obviously hasn't don't joke
about anything very incisive to say
about it and so it's it's actually I was
sort of embarrassed for him nothing
incisive to say Wow just you know we owe
the news commentary was missing from
your confidence like special do you mean
that he just I
he just needed to know that he shouldn't
joke about your thing right used to be
man woman now so just make sure we're
clear that's it I mean it would be fine
if he just didn't do the trans jokes Oh
someone else yep and by the way don't
make the trans amputee jokes and then
you have somebody else going and don't
make the trans ageist jokes because I
believe that I'm a six year old girl
named Stefani who screws harley-davidson
riders and everyone says don't make
jokes about me then you have Hannah cats
be saying don't make jokes about lesbian
fat Australian to refuse to do comedy
and call it a comedy special I mean at
what point you just just just admit you
don't like it and move on I'm
embarrassed for him oh well I'm sure
let's get Dave Chappelle on my landline
with the speed dial one of the most
prolific comedic minds of our
generation all of a sudden this is
something that's important to note all
of a sudden they did it with Dennis
Miller became unfunny overnight right no
I didn't claim it's embarrassing they do
the same thing with more McDonald grant
Norman Donald Dennis Miller they did it
at one point with Bill burr when they
thought he was getting problematic and
now they're doing it with Dave Chappelle
how did he become so unfunny so quickly
yeah if you like Jesus where he touches
Mike and he's losing his powers I've
done this with Dave Chappelle and
they've done it with with us on this
show what they try to do when they say
this person isn't funny they separate
the actual joke from what offends them
right they did this with when they go
well what Steven Steven creditor claims
it's jokes but I don't think that
calling someone a lisp speak a Mexican
is a joke well that wasn't the joke
that's what offended you the joke was go
watch the apology video that's 20
minutes long of jokes that's not the
joke like with Dave Chappelle the joke
about people driving the games driving
the car and trans people making the ride
feel like it's way longer than it needs
to be that's the joke you were offended
by the fact that he made fun of
transgender so they say well I don't see
the joke in making fun of transgenders
that's not the joke you're separating
what offended you from what the actual
joke was and that's why they don't want
to run the clips and here's a general
rule that I use when it applies anything
jokes are commentary right if you extend
the clip that you see that typically
generates outrage
extend it 30 seconds in either direction
it'll usually go one of two directions
if you extend it it's either less
offensive or you understand the point to
it or it gets worse for example don't we
do that joke about Christine Blasi Ford
yeah the authorities still what are
considered distinct possibility that
she's a lying [ __ ] was the joke yeah
yeah well the Young Turks I hate you
know we can't use them anymore once we
can surpass them but that last she was
gonna be a lot of fun yep um when people
extended it 30 seconds in either
direction what they saw was that we use
all of the evidence as the setup and the
punch line was at police officers and
people said oh you know what I don't
even necessarily but it's it's really
not as offensive as you make it seem now
if you extend it for example someone
saying that I don't know I like seeing
American War heroes getting killed in
Iraq and we deserved 9/11 you go oh
what's that that sounds that and you
extend it and it's just them going
seriously and think we deserve 9/11
seriously I hope this guy gets taken out
by jihadist and you go
that I excited more context it's almost
like it's worse that's a rule that I use
separate what offends you from the
actual context and content of the joke
and then whatever it is that offends you
give it more context give it 30 seconds
and eat in both directions and then if
at that point you're not sure give it a
minute in both directions it's usually
pretty easy to find out where they're
coming from and there is nothing sadder
than while we're talking about this then
watching woke leftist explain comedy to
one of the greatest comics of our time I
think that's what bothers me about this
so much right now is this this this more
discern izing this read I hate to use
the word virtue signaling we do have to
get to John O'Hurley a little bit JP
term and let's assume though that the
left is being genuine I always typically
assume that they're being dinner let's
assume that everyone is actually
offended and genuinely hurt by these
jokes okay here how about this you don't
have to find it funny you just have to
acknowledge that it's comedy let's start
with that start with that context over
content and then maybe we can find some
common ground hey there youtube you or
if you like this video click one of
these other videos playing in a box up
there and hit subscribe or the
notification Bell if you're already
subscribed so you can find out about our
new non controversial videos which don't
ruffle any feathers and of course are
not a violation of YouTube's algorithms
everyone's welcome here except oh I
don't know if we are but it's our
channel not sure how that works